I'll tell you what not to do look at the
rest of the market and take the average
and then go a little bit lower which is
what most people do it only comes down
to how much value you are providing on
average to the customers that are coming
to you and then taking a percentage of
that value it has nothing to do with how
much it costs you to deliver it how much
time how much effort any of that it's
literally just what is my average
outcome over what period of time and
then how can I take a percentage of that
outcome on average that I deliver to
customers I'm a big believer in 10 to 20
percent of the value that you generate
for the average customer